l'archéologie des ploucs ça suffit ça
suffit pas non j entends pas ainsi vous
avez trouvé je vais quand même donné le
deuxième titre
elle a aussi file la vidéo qui s'appelle
la poésie contre attaque
la chaîne s'est passé sauvage et c'est
clotilde chamussy qui arrive tout de
suite tu applaudis c'est là
[Musique]
bienvenue tout ça alors on va parler
tout doucement parce que clotilde elle a
plus beaucoup de voir et d'obtenir des
chiottes
oui on va faire ça tous deux alors tu es
diplômés d'archéologique le tienne tu
animes la chaîne passé les sauvages
depuis qu'en 2015 2016 2016 et tu as
aussi dernièrement coécrit un livre qui
cartonne à s'il cartonne moi partout je
vois sur les réseaux sociaux ça
s'appelle retour vers le palais au c'est
quoi exactement
c'est un livre qui vulgarise la
préhistoire par thème la musique le sexe
l'alimentation tout y passe et s'est
donné aussi s'est dessinée s'est
illustré par aurélie bordeaux n'a que je
salue parce que je la connais bien
alors tu faisais partie du vortex saison
1 à quoi on va voir ce que ça a donné
bienvenue au vortex moi c'est clotilde
pour le premier épisode d'une série sur
quelques grandes révolutions de
l'histoire une l'interprétation des
symboles en archéologie d'ailleurs un
jeu risqué pour ne pas dire quasi
impossible alors à quand remontent les
premières représentations une
[Musique]
c'est lors de la cueillette
l'invention du métal ne transforme pas
la nature des relations humaines et leur
degré d'intensité
voilà à puce
ce qui est marrant pouvoir que lui par
exemple c'est d'imaginer dans 2000 ans
comment on va interpréter les objets
qu'on a aujourd'hui
allez on remet tout dans l'ordre alors
clotilde d'ailleurs dit applaudissent
parce qu'ils veulent que tu commences le
one man show
tu as choisi de lui parler de
l'archéologie mais du futur ouais ouais
bah écoute tu vois le timer il marche
pas mais tu as 7 minutes
c'est à toi auteur ap la famille et ça
on sort merci d'être là
alors quand on a proposé de parler de
l'archéologie du futur me suis vite
rendu compte qu'il y avait déjà pas mal
de choses sur ce thème des articles des
expositions à savoir comment les
archéologues du futur comprendront-ils
notre civilisation
alors c'est pas du tout langue que j'ai
choisi j'ai décidé de m'en tenir à
l'intitulé c'est à dire que sera
l'archéologie demain parce que
l'archéologie comme les autres sciences
dépend totalement des méthodes des
outils qu'elle emploie c'est par exemple
à la découverte de la lunette
astronomique qui a permis en 709 à
galilée de voir pour la première fois
les satellites de jupiter et de
comprendre un peu mieux le système
solaire bas pour l'archéologie c'est
pareil c'est la précision des outils et
des méthodes d'analysé qui permet d'en
savoir plus sur les sociétés passées
c'est pour cette raison que les
premières fouilles se sont concentrés
sur les édifices les plus imposants
qu'on pouvait dégager avec de simples
pioche parce qu'on n'avait pas d'autres
outils et alors quand des outils sont
arrivés on a pu accéder à des éléments
de plus en plus précis sur les humains
du passé par exemple on a le microscope
qui permet de détecter des pollens qui
sont les témoins du climat
préhistoriques mais aussi des parasites
qui ont retrouve dans les excréments
fossilisés
on a aussi le logiciel de dessin de
photomontages qui permettent de
restituer des sites en trois dimensions
qu'est-ce qu'on a d'autres on à la
datation carbone 14 coups qu'à la dendre
haut
nos logis dendrochronologie c'est
l'adaptation à partir des cernes de bois
et tout ça ça permet d'avoir des
datations toujours plus précises mais on
a aussi on en voit aussi des impulsions
électromagnétiques dans le sol pour
restituer des enfin pour repérer plus
tôt des vestiges enfouis et puis
dernièrement dayal et les drones
alors les drones pour l'archéologie
c'est génial parce que ça permet d'avoir
des vues d'ensemble des sites
quand auparavant tenez vous bien on
galérait avec des cerfs-volants vous le
promets je les fais d'état d'année faute
au cerf-volant ça ne marche jamais vous
finissez à 22h vous êtes content c'est
bien et voilà il s'agit ce pourrait être
très longue alors que sera l'archéologie
demain l'évolution des techniques et pas
près de s'arrêter
et donc on peut s'attendre à beaucoup
beaucoup d'avancées pour pour l'avenir
c'est pour cette raison par exemple que
le site de pompéi n'a pas été fouillé
dans son intégralité
ça et le manque de financement mais bon
c'est pas le sujet on a en effet gardé
une partie du site aux fouilles futur
dans l'espoir qu'il y ait des nouveaux
moyens des nouveaux outils pour déceler
des traces passé jusqu alors une
aversion bon l'un des domaines les plus
prometteurs c'est la génétique
l'histoire d'humanité ça avant tout des
c'est une histoire de migration et la
paléogénétique est une discipline qui
permet de les reconstituer comme je fais
du tout spécialiste de la paléogénétique
c'est la partie de mon texte que je
connais le moins en séquençant et en
comparant des génomes fossiles on est
capable de faire des liens entre eux et
donc de retracer les mouvements
d'individus de populations à travers les
siècles à travers les régions
c'est génial sauf que l'adn se dégrade
dans le temps et qu'il est très
difficile de tirer des informations net
à partir d'ossements vieux de plusieurs
milliers d'années c'est comme ça qu'on
étudie alors il ya des chercheurs du
cnrs de l'université de lyon 1 et 2 le
ls de lyon qui ont mis au point une
méthode ils sont en train de l'élaborer
en 2010 est donc c'est assez récent
s'appelle la méthode sert se2 rs qui
permet d'accéder à une partie de l'adn
plus dégradées alors serre c'est sûr
safe in
raisonnante rahman spectroscopie voilà
vous laisserai regarder ça donc ça
s'avère très prometteur pour l'avenir et
le boulot des archéologues maintenant
dans le domaine sous marin qui a un
domaine qui me tient particulièrement à
coeur
on compte beaucoup sur l'arrivée des
robots alors on en a déjà celle des roms
est mauvais c'est des drones sous-marins
si vous voulez et la stanford est en
train de bosser sur un prototype
d'humanoïdes robotisée qui serait
capable de descendre à 2000 mètres de
lui le maître c'est incroyable à l'heure
actuelle un plongeur qui plonge avec des
bouteilles classiques y descend à 60
mètres à 60 mètres on reste 5 minutes
c'est très éprouvant physiquement c'est
risqué donc ce serait bien que des
robots puissent remplacer les
archéologues à ces profondeurs
donc c'est bien de a et ce bon pardon ce
robot il s'appelle au chanoine voilà le
dernier truc que je voulais vous dire
donc c'est bien beau tous ces progrès
technologique mais c'est oublié un truc
fondamental c'est que l'archéologie
n'est pas une science technologique
l'archéologie est une science humaine et
les humains c'est la ceca screen la
veille
ça fait pas ce qu'on leur dit de faire
ou pire ça change d'avis au dernier
moment ça voyage ça rêve parfois ça se
drogue
parfois ça croit en dieu alors dieu ça
peut être un animal végétal un fils de
charpentier
peu importe vous pourrez bien à l'entée
tous les supers microscope les plus
beaux laser aéroporté ça ne suffira
jamais à comprendre société dans sa
globalité dans sa complexité
donc les ni les progrès les plus
significatifs de la discipline ne seront
sans doute pas dû à une révolution
technologique mais plutôt à
l'interdisciplinarité
récemment c'est l'ethnologie avec des
travaux porter chez des fins fête chez
des peuples du présent qui a été à
l'origine de travaux très novateur pour
l'archéologie
donc c'est vraiment du croisement des
sciences sociologie histoire chimie
génétique que naîtront de nouvelles
idées stimulante et en définitive c'est
le fondement nous
m de l'archéologie qui s'est toujours
nourri des autres sciences
chaque archéologue et un petit peu
spécialiste d'une autre discipline
topographie zoologie botanique
métallurgie géologie etc etc
enfin montagne en marche pas je m'en
fous je peux prendre mon temps finir
là-dessus toute façon c'est mon dernier
point pour qu'ils aient une archéologie
du futur il faut aussi et surtout se
préoccuper de faire perdurer les
conditions dans lesquelles elles
s'exercent l'archéologie du futur ça
avant tout un cadre légal ambitieux cela
veut dire bien sûr financer la recherche
universitaire mais aussi pérenniser et
étendre l'archéologie préventive qui
enregistre et sauvegardent les vestiges
en permanence sur tout le territoire et
donc en interdisant les prospections
privé en faisant du diagnostic
archéologique une obligation légale en
2001 et en créant donc l'inrap
c'est l'institut national de recherches
archéologiques préventives
eh bien l'état a professionnalisé
l'archéologie et à donner un avenir aux
recherches ce qui est capital parce
qu'il faut bien avoir en tête qu'il ya
beaucoup de pays dans le monde où de
telles conditions ne sont pas réunies et
et où les vestiges pardon son eau sont
pillées au pire sont détruits au gré de
projets immobiliers ou
d'extraction donc ce qui menace le plus
la discipline c'est la corruption qui
permet d'échapper aux fouilles de
sauvegarde c'est l'impunité des
prétendus antiquaires qui recèle des
vestiges pillés donc le futur
d'archéologie c'est peut-être une
nouvelle charte de l'unesco protégeant
l'intégralité des vestiges
archéologiques et pas seulement 1000
grands sites étiqueté patrimoine mondial
voilà merci merci merci et en plus ça va
garder un tout petit peu de voix on va
te reposer
bravo quand même alors je te présente
aussi nouvel invité julie brh qui vous
est ambassadrice doctorante ambassadrice
de l'université d'aix marseille vous
êtes écologue votre thèse c'est sur les
espèces invasives
c'est bien ça c'est bien ça juste à côté
marie-george doctorante également
ambassadrice de l'université de lille où
vous êtes géologue est en fait pour
amasser des petits cailloux un petit peu
partout dans le monde pour voir comment
les montagnes se sont constitués et une
évolution des petits cailloux des gros
cailloux et des grains de sable aussi
j'ai alors tout les deux vos thèses
aussi je le répète elles sont racontées
ici et vous comprendrez tout donc c'est
génial qu'abriel on vous connaît déjà
je voudrais vous faire réagir il ya
beaucoup de choses dans ce que tu viens
de dire je fait réagir mariant
appartient lui moi je sais que céder à
petit
ouais ouais justement c'est bien moi ya
un thème qui m'intéresse dans ce que
viennent dire claude hills et
l'interdisciplinarité on peut peut-être
se retrouver là dessus est ce que vous
pouvez penser aussi que aujourd'hui les
sciences sont en train d'évoluer dans ce
sens serait ce que sur les sciences de
l'avenir moi je pense surtout que moi je
m'intéresse au débat public et vos
questions aux politiques de comment
est-ce qu'on choisit le futur est en
fait les scientifiques chacun dans son
domaine
regarde un objet et sont capables de
dire dans le futur il a évolué comme ci
comme ça mais si on veut construire une
image du futur qu'on peut discuter sur
le débat public il faut construire une
image qu'ils soient pas la somme de tout
ce qui est possible pour chaque objet
mais qu'ils soient des combinaisons
crédible et pour avoir une question sur
la fin pour savoir si c'est crédible que
le spécialiste des noix elles évolueront
comme ça que le spécialiste du climat
dit ça peut évoluer comme ça que le
spécialiste de l'eau dce à peu en fait
il va falloir sélectionnés pour chacun
quelque chose qui soit plausible et
donner à voir une grande image et ça
pour faire ça il faut faire dialoguer
les sciences parce que les conditions
pour que ce pour que pousse des plantes
et bah ça va aussi dépendre du climat ça
va aussi dépendre de l'eau ça va aussi
dépendre du sol et donc on a besoin de
ce dialogue pour savoir où est ce qu'on
va
julie et marie c'est quelque chose que
vous ressentez aussi tu lis
spécifiquement dans mon sujet donc
aborder la gestion des espèces invasives
on a besoin de données archéologiques
qu'on appelle ça donc des données
fossiles d'animaux qu'ils avaient avant
pour comprendre quelles espèces ont
disparu qu'elle était
l'espace qui étaient là avant et ensuite
pour l'interdisciplinarité effectivement
on a un sujet qui peut porter à débat
sur des questions sociales parce qu'on
on gère les espèces invasives par
éradication souvent donc ça peut
soulever des questions éthiques et
politiques
mise en place de
mesures de biosécurité de c'est un
ensemble effectivement bah oui dans la
géologie en géologie par exemple pour
l'évolution des montagnes on peut pas
prendre en compte qu'un seul facteur
parce que c'est une région qui est très
large
donc on doit prendre en compte aussi
l'impact du climat à court terme à long
terme l'impact par exemple des séismes
du volcanisme et moi les méthodes que je
fais je suis autant de la physique de la
chimie dans ma thèse pour essayer de
répondre à un problème et je dois aussi
prendre en compte toutes les études qui
ont été faites sur le climat sur le
magma tiznit et c'est donc en fait on
doit regrouper énormément de
connaissances pour pouvoir comprendre
comment une chaîne de montagnes évolué
c'est pas possible de tout connaître
non cette règle donc il faut travailler
avec les autres c'est ça donc on
travaille avec des gens qui sont
spécialisés dans d'autres disciplines et
nous ensuite on essaie de publier
quelque chose qui nous permet de
raconter l'histoire des montagnes au
mieux alors je dis pas parce que j'en
sais rien j'ai pas fait d'enquêté si
autrefois les scientifiques travaillent
est davantage dans leur coin mais j'ai
l'impression aujourd'hui il ya davantage
de moyens pour que tout le monde
communique
non oui c'est ce qu'on fait en général
même si on a le matériel pour travailler
dans notre université ce qu'on fait
c'est qu'on essaye d'aller faire les
expériences dans une autre université
pour faire justement des collaborations
avec d'autres labos rencontrer d'autres
personnes et donc ça c'est ce qui est
intéressant dans la recherche du pouvoir
rencontrer plein de gens comme ça tout
le temps sur plein de disciplines
différentes
clotilde jeu pas te faire trop trop
parler mais alors à la fin c'est un
plaidoyer un quand même que oui non mais
tu as raison il faudrait une nouvelle
charte de l'unesco
on protège passé les traces de nos
civilisations
ben on protège souvent les mêmes c'est à
dire les édifices des rois c'est une
toute petite partie de la population
quand même
on s'intéresse moins aux constructions
qui touche le peuple c'est à dire bah
vos futurs vestiges en gros vous êtes le
peuple comme nous ici
bon c'est une question d'accord dernière
question ça sert à quoi cette question
aussi de l'asie est ce que moi je peux
fossilisés enfin quelles conditions il
faut pour que je fasse un bon fossiles
rapidement enceinte était à mais moi je
suis pas un mince et non les fossiles on
s'est compliqué en étant dans une ville
pour devenir un bon fossiles non ok
alors à quoi ça sert de fouiller le
passé est ce que ça permet de mieux
prévenir l'avenir de mieux l'envisager
bas
à quoi ça sert bastos m'avaient bah oui
évidemment ça tu as voulu savoir d'où on
vient pourquoi on a fait ses choix l'a
donc d'accord
écoutez je vous remercie beaucoup merci
clotilde est revenue avec cette scène je
vous conseille à nouveau et en plus ce
n'est pas de la pub
il est gratuit 1 donc si vous passez
demain on peut vous le donner et il est
vraiment très très intéressant pour en
savoir plus sur les travaux de nos
doctorants
merci beaucoup d'avoir été avec nous
[Musique]